hello and thank you for joining us for a
demonstration of some new tools that can
help enable end-to-end causal inference
at scale
i'm eleanor dillon i'm part of the alice
team at microsoft research new england
where we've developed the econml toolkit
and i'm joined by amit sharma at
microsoft research india and the
co-creator of the do y toolkit
so today we want to talk a little bit
about these two python toolkits that
we've developed and how they can help
use causal machine learning and the
latest techniques for large scale data
then we'll spend some time digging
deeper into a specific use case of how
you'd use these tool two toolkits in
practice
many of the early advances in machine
learning were really designed to think
about prediction problems
when we use prediction models we're
making an implicit assumption that
things will basically continue as they
have been so the relationships between
data features that we're using to
predict many features into one outcome
will hold in the future and that
prediction will remain valid
when we think about changing our
behavior that in some assumption of
prediction models is violated so when we
want to think about what would happen if
we changed behavior we need to use a
different set of causal models
prediction models can give us really
misleading answers to these questions
because the feature that is the best
predictor may not have a direct causal
effect
for example
past sales may be a good predictor of
future sales but if we did something to
artificially inflate sales today we
wouldn't necessarily expect that sales
would increase a lot in the future
it turns out that many business relevant
questions that data scientists are
thinking about are really better served
by causal models rather than prediction
models
a b experiments are the standard way to
think about
answering a causal question so if i
change an algorithm would it lead to a
higher success rate
but lots of policy decisions are also
really driven by causal questions if we
adopt this new treatment and policy
how will it
lead to a change in outcomes maybe a
healthier patient more revenue for a
business
we can also use this to think about the
changes we've made in the past
knowing what i do now and the way that
outcomes changed did my policy really
help or hurt what i was trying to change
we can also think about attributing
credit to many different interventions
that we've made in the past are people
buying more of a product because of my
recommendation algorithm would they have
bought anyway was there something else
that affected their choice
so we know that it's important to think
about things in a causal way sometimes
instead of a prediction
but it's often difficult to figure out
how to do that in practice
so there's two fundamental challenges in
causal inference
one is that even more than prediction
problems the validity of causal analysis
always depends on assumptions
so data is not enough we really need to
be clear about what we believe
relationships will be
because of this
causal inference has traditionally
been the domain of specialists like
economists who are practiced in
developing and articulating these
assumptions
however data sets have also become
increasingly
high dimensional and large a lot of
traditional economic techniques for
causal inference built in very strong
assumptions
to use simple transparent models that
work with limited data
our new capacities with machine learning
and large data sets allow us to relax
some of those assumptions but it means
that models become increasingly
transparent
non-transparent and difficult to
interpret and evaluate
economy do i can help with both of these
challenges both to help articulate
assumptions clearly and understand our
results and to implement increasingly
complex economic models with more
realistic assumptions
do y and econ ml are two python packages
that help bring causal inference to a
wider audience away from specialists and
economists
they implement the latest in causal
machine learning models which have
flexible minimal assumptions
and help to make those assumptions more
transparent for users
a unified api brings together many of
these latest tools some of them we've
developed in the house as part of
microsoft research but we've also
programmed up the advances in academia
and from many other sources
finally we put them in a familiar
interface that's built on standard
python packages that most data
scientists are already familiar with to
enable
implementing of these complex models
with only a few command lines
no toolkit can remove any domain
expertise
and human input in causal reasoning
but the traditional process required a
decision maker with domain knowledge and
expertise to frame the question
and then specialists like economists to
choose an appropriate model fit the
assumptions to the model implement the
model and then interpret the results
do i and econ ml can't remove that first
step where you need a decision maker
with domain expertise to frame the
question but they can make those second
and third steps simpler
so i'm now going to turn this over to my
colleague ahmet to talk a little bit
more about how these toolkits work in
practice
thank you eleanor now i'll go deeper
into each step of causal influence and
show how these libraries can help you
conduct a causal analysis
uh as eleanor mentioned there are three
steps framing of the causal question
then estimation of the causal effect and
then finally evaluation
of how you're good your causal estimate
is and as we'll see because domain
expertise and assumptions are so
important
evaluation also becomes an important
part
so in the first step the framing
it is important to articulate the
assumptions formally
and also formulate the current causal
estimate both of the steps can be done
using y
so here we are transferring the domain
experts knowledge into a formal
framework so this helps one in helping
them transparently establish what are
the assumptions and it also helps in
sharing those assumptions
with other people and getting reviews
the second step once you have figured
out this is my causal question and these
are the methods that are allowed to be
estimated
on that causal question
uh now comes
the answer of estimation so here we
often have high dimensional data
and we also may be interested in the
treatment effect on a particular set of
people or a small set of people
and so here we need cutting edge
personalized causal inference tools
that econml provides this is based on
recent and research
that we and others have done
and with this tool uh you get a battery
of different estimators that you can use
for your problem and compare them
and finally the question is of
evaluation
so now you may want to know
how good is your estimate and also you
may want to understand
what is the model doing right and so
here you get interpretability
and presentation of causal effects in a
visual way
as well as ways to test your assumptions
and test the validity of your estimate
itself
in the next three slides i'll talk about
each of these problems and how our
solution helps you
do this in a methodological way
so first for any kind of causal problem
a causal graph is a well-established way
of expressing your assumptions and
that's exactly what our toolkit helps
you do
so as i'm showing you an example here
as a domain expert
you can enter the variables that you're
interested in what's the treatment
what's the outcome what causal effect is
interesting to you and then also say how
other variables are affecting it right
and the power of do calculus and a lot
of causal inference work that has been
done in the past decade now helps us
kind of automatically figure out first
if the causal effect is identifiable
which means given even infinite infinite
data can you find out the causal effect
and second it also tells you which are
the methods that you can use for your
problem
so i've just written a couple of them
here
automatically based on the graph our
library can tell you whether the
backdoor criterion front door
instrumental variables mediation and so
on which ones are applicable for your
specific problem
once you have that information
you would now want to know how can i
estimate the causal effect and here you
get the finite data issues right so now
you have to think about
what kinds of
data set you have what are the
dimensions of the features that you have
to control for uh and also who on whom
do you want to estimate the effect right
and so here we provide you multiple
options
so that you can find the best method
that may apply for your particular data
set uh if it's just average treatment
effect that you're interested in
you may look at simple methods like
matching or stratification or
propensity-based scoring
these methods have the benefit that they
are interpretable
and very easy to use
but often you'll find in a situation
where you have high dimensional data and
so advanced machine learning methods are
needed there this is also true
especially if you want to find out
conditional treatment effects for
specific populations
so here we provide uh some of the most
recent research methods for example
double ml orthogonal random forests meta
learners intend to treat
drivs and many more methods that you can
look at
and the goal there is to
help you have one library which has all
the methods available so that they're
easily swappable and also easily
comparable for a particular problem and
this brings us to the last part of
causal inference which is how do you
interpret and evaluate the robustness of
an estimate because remember we don't
have cross validation or something
simple as you have in predictive models
where you can immediately know how good
your model is and so here you need a
multi-pronged approach to look at what
the model is doing and inspect that with
the domain knowledge that you have
so we would first want to interpret the
estimate uh interpret the role of
confounders and driving treatment and
outcome with shop and we'd also want to
look at the personalized treatment
effects and our libraries provide and
tree interpreter for you to look at the
policy and how it's doing for different
sets of people
on the robustness side we would want to
test whether the assumptions we made
were actually true
so partly we want to see whether the
data itself satisfies those assumptions
and second we would also want to create
some simulated data
where we know the causal assumptions and
check how our estimator is doing
so one quick example i'm showing you
here in the graph is imagine that you
have a treatment and
an outcome and a confounder that you
need to condition on we can create an
alternative universe where there's a
placebo treatment which means this
treatment is completely randomly
generated
and now we give the same data set this
new data set sorry to the estimator
right and the goal is that now the
estimator should definitely return zero
as the treatment effect because we have
completely randomly generated this
treatment value and so these are ways in
which almost like debugging you can look
at the estimate and check how good it is
for your problem
with that we'll now switch into a case
study
this could be a
obvious way of showing uh how our
libraries work and this would also give
you a hands-on experience uh what
eleanor and i will do now is that we'll
take you through this case study
together
and show the capabilities of these
libraries so our problem is customer
segmentation
uh imagine a media company this is a
very common problem they want to
offer discounts but they want to target
discounts to customers right
and here it's very difficult to do
experiments and a b tests so they prefer
to use their large historical data
two questions they want to ask first
what is the causal effect of these
discounts on demand
and second which customers are more
responsive to discounts
with the first they gain a knowledge
about their customers and their system
but the second one is interesting
because they can now also create
policies and decide how to allocate
their discounts to customers okay so
let's just dive in let's see how these
libraries can help
before that a bit of setup
we are here using simulated data
the reason is that with simulated data
we know the true causal effect and we
can benchmark the estimates that we get
but of course in a real world scenario
you would not have
this data simulated and you would not
know the true effect therefore
things like refutations and
interpretation would be important
we have the standard data here
just to give you a sense we have the
user's account age their age average
hours they spend online
their friends if they have membership or
not
the songs they purchased their income
and so on and so this is usually you can
think of as a user profile and their
activity
that we have access to
and the question would be what would be
the causal effect right so the first
problem is framing
and here's where you can use 2y to input
your assumptions and you are given back
a graph that interprets and shows you
what assumptions you're making about the
problem right so what we're showing in
the first step is that you're
initializing
a gate estimator saying that i would
like to use a method called linear dml
uh and you're also saying that you want
to actually estimate uh the causal
effect
then you can use 2y to actually
visualize the causal pathways and also
specify now which variables are what
right so what's the treatment what's the
outcome and also what are the
confounders so these are variables that
you would like to control on
in the second step
you would now want to know which
estimation methods are applicable right
so this is uh in this case we already
chose with the linear
dml model
but you might want to know first of all
if that's a good choice and second maybe
you are there are other methods that you
can use which would be more beneficial
for your problem uh so what we do here
is that we're using do calculus to find
out whether back door is applicable or
whether instrumental variables are
applicable and so on and as you can see
this library automatically tells you
that estimate one backdoor is applicable
so now we can talk a little bit about
understanding the
variation and the personalization and
the causal effects
so for the first step that i presented
we used linear dml which imposes some
assumptions on the relationship between
the treatment the price in this case and
the outcome the sales
the advantage of imposing that
assumption is that it can make estimates
a bit faster and
more precise because you're adding your
knowledge but if that knowledge is
incorrect if it's not a linear
relationship you might want to use an
estimator that we do here like a causal
forest which allows a free relationship
between the treatment and the outcome
so here we've estimated our causal
forest and then we've plotted the
estimated effect in blue
over the true effect which we know in
this simulation in orange and you can
see that we find a very good
relationship between the
uh both income which we think affects
how
price will affect sales and the
relationship between price and sales so
our estimated effect is
more more negative which in this case
means that when you raise the price more
you decrease sales more
for lower income and a smaller effect
for higher income and our estimates
match the true effect very well
if we did not have the true data
and the simulation we would now also
want to check whether our estimate is
good right
and one of the examples i'm showing here
is that of the placebo refuter that we
just talked about and so what your code
is doing here is that it's saying i have
the estimate and i have my data set but
i now just want to simulate a slightly
different data set where the treatment
is replaced by a completely gaussian
random variable right and that's exactly
what this test does and your expectation
is that the method should return zero as
the treatment effect if it does not we
give you
a p-value here to let you know when this
test has detected some problem with your
method and you may want to go back and
change some assumptions
luckily in this case as expected the new
effect is very close to zero and the
p-value is above 0.05 so we can conclude
that at least this test
is okay
one thing i want to highlight is that we
cannot prove that the estimate is
correct using these checks but what we
do is that we provide you a bunch of
such checks so that at least you can go
through and weed out any of the bad
estimators that you may have
so finally now that we have our
personalized causal effects
and we feel reasonably confident about
the assumptions that we use to make this
model we may want to take another step
to
take our personalized causal estimates
and turn them into policies that we can
implement
if we had a lot of features that we
thought might influence the
responsiveness of demand to prices we
might use a tree to highlight which of
those features were the most important
in this case we think income is the only
important feature that drives how
responsive
users are to changes in price
so here we use a tree policy interpreter
from econ ml to
create a rule in this case
it finds that we should divide our
sample from income less than one and
greater than one in the simulated data
and you can see that for these
relatively low income users there's a
large average
treatment effect
that again is negative showing that they
buy less when the price is high
for the sample that's higher income the
average kate is
much smaller and closer to zero
so you can see that if you implement
this suggested policy and target the
discount only at those users that have
the
highest responsiveness to changes in
price
you have higher revenue than
if you give everyone a discount or if
you give no one a discount
so using these toolkits can improve your
outcome by targeting your discounts to
the right customers
this notebook is available on the econ
ml github account and you can also
browse many more notebooks on both do y
and econ mls github
we would love for you to check out the
documents and give us feedback these are
open source libraries
we would also love your contributions
for more information you can check out
the links below
and with that i thank you for your
attention
of course 2y and economy are the result
of a collaborative effort of a larger
team you can reach out to any of us
for comments and feedback thank you
you